Katie is with us in Milwaukee hi Katie
how are you hi great better than I
deserve how are you better than I
deserve
what's up I just actually graduated
residency and so the opposite of
previous color and I have a huge debt of
about five hundred thousand dollars from
medical school and a little bit from
grad school it's my only debt outside of
my home and my question is where would
that fit in my baby steps given that
it's so big how did you get a half a
million dollars for med school and well
I had 50,000 from graduate school I have
a master's degree and then I went to a
private medical school that was about
sixty thousand a year and I wasn't
married at the time so they don't allow
you to work in medical school so I I
didn't have any living expenses so all
you want to be very very expensive med
school is what you're saying yeah double
right and they live down south in Fort
Lauderdale so it was you pay double what
other people paid right good lord
so you have a specialization I'm sorry
what was that what what field of
medicine are you going into it oh I my
family's family medicine doctor and I'm
just about to start my new my new job in
as an attending
as a resident no no no I'm finished with
resin or you're finished
I just finished and so I'm about to eat
Michael is about to get very big and I
just want to know what is your income
right now my husband and I make together
about 150,000 which I often know and
with a new job will make about 400 okay
then you don't do anything you clean
this debt up right no Scott you are in a
very deep unbelievable hole that is
taking my breath away that's the bad
news the good news is you have a very
large shovel use it right little black
thing you have like a college student
and pay it off as fast as you possibly
can should I not say for retirement no
to set up oh you should do nothing but
get rid of this disaster that is looming
over your head as fast as possible four
hundred thousand means you're going to
pay taxes
about 150 almost and you're going to
live on about 50 so that leaves you
about 200 so it's going to take you
about two and a half years to clean this
up
but you're not doing nothing no vacation
no cars no houses don't go out to eat
honey you should be scared
get rid of it fast got it because that's
something if something happens to you
you know that causes you to have an
inability to work for some reason at the
level that you're working now you have a
really serious nightmare of a situation
right the only thing the only saving
grace in this conversation is your
fabulous income oh yeah and my husband I
paid off both of our cars and his
student loans and this is our only bet
left besides our home and so great I do
it
that's like let's do it very very very
very fast and then I say then think
about it then you've got a $400,000
income to live the less you risk your
life with oh my gosh I know I don't know
what I'm going to do that kind of money
I even gave I get outrageous generosity
and change your family tree sounds
awesome babe thanks so much hey thanks
for calling in oh that takes my breath
away
I can't imagine five hundred thousand
dollars us to run huh good news is she
got a great job
Oh God think thank you Laurie oh my
goodness gracious hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]